il y un peu plus de deux heures que le
soleil s'est levé sur la baie des
flamands la plage de la française est
occupé en majorité par des seniors
frites à la main les plus sportifs
patauge dans l'eau entre exercices et
papotages il est permis d'apprécier les
pertes eu de la mer c'est le meilleur
médicament qui existent au monde
en plus on a la chance d'avoir deux fois
l'une des plages les meilleurs de la
martinique en qualité des eaux
l'autre manière de profiter des
bienfaits de luz et en y associant le
sport plusieurs clubs à sur le court
plage de la française le 10 et mais audi
sont les jours d'affluence
daniel est moniteur depuis 25 ans ils
étaient moins de l'accroissement du
nombre de candidats l'aquagym les
personnes âgées ils ont pris conscience
que cette nécessité de faire de
l'activité ou leur bien-être et c'est
vrai qu'ils viennent de plus en plus et
maintenant il ya des structures
maintenant visionner en place où elle
est point est donc donc maintenant et
ils ont pas une conscience parce que les
docteurs qui ont un travail et dans les
municipalités un peu partout on s'occupe
du troisième âge s'occuper les seniors
ça fait surtout se chouchouter les
voyages tout compris tire déjà plus de
la moitié des revenus des plus de 50 ans
dans l'hexagone en martinique aussi nous
aider saab se divertir
j'avais à massinissa pour les français
choisir quand je veux bien mais sur
pourquoi pas même si j'ai fait en six
soirs cette fois je vais je veux pas
payer
on va pas rester parce qu'on à la
retraite sans vraiment se cultiver
c'était avec le cerveau éveillé ou ne
pas tomber vraiment comme les vieux
d'abord je suis allé à
espace d'art y apprendre à masser rio de
lundi numéro je trouve qu'il ya des
choses que vous avez des enfants en
france je vais parler avec mes enfants
je les vois c'est important c'est le dis
bon déjà pelle clown dg du club med
amedeo des aînés qui s'organise pendant
leur retraite c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour une population qui
vieillit les seniors sont parfois
tellement dynamique que la notion d'âge
prend aujourd'hui un tout autre sens
d'ailleurs cette qui en parlent le mieux
on peut être âgés d'être très actif et
puis on peut être jeune et puis je